they they have no choice in a sense
because one normally would call a
referendum either before the beginning
of a negotiation to seek a popular
mandate or else after the conclusion of
the negotiation to seek a ratification
at least a political ratification if not
a legal one this suddenly called
referendum in the midst of a negotiation
of a tough negotiation looks a bit more
like tactical and to some extent cynical
move meant to rain force Prime Minister
tsipras hand in the negotiation I am Not
sure that that result would be achieved
if the position recommended by the
government that is voting no succeeds
because in that case the dismay around
Europe and also with the IMF for the way
in which Mississip russ has been
handling the whole relationship with
Europe may well make things more
difficult for him in spite of what would
appear to have been a popular support I
mean mr. tsipras says as you know that a
no vote would not mean that Greece had
to leave the euro or indeed the European
Union do you think that's true yes that
may be true but what he does say also is
that the success of the no would rain
force his bargaining position and as I
said I strongly doubt that that would be
the consequence paradoxically the way in
which the rest of Europe and the IMF
would go on in
negotiations with the Greek government
may be a more open if not flexible but a
more psychologically open negotiation in
case the yes wins and if I were mr.
tsipras I would not tie my hands to
saying that a yes would be a rejection
of the positions of the government the
government has been ill-advised but if i
wear mrs. tsipras i would wish at this
point the yes to win we should make his
life in the negotiation difficult at any
rate a bit less difficult than if he is
proclaimed objective the no Victor